disposable income is perhaps the best
measure of our standard of living and
what these bars are showing you going
all the way back to 1955 here is just
how much it has grown
over the course of the last few decades
and so what you can see here anything
above the line means we're getting
better off and i think below the line
means we're getting worse off and just
look those years where we're getting
better off are far far more common than
the years where we're getting worse off
there's only a few of these red bars
there you can see a few there that's the
financial crisis but here's the thing i
want you to note and if we kind of like
zoom out
you can probably see that bar there
that is the deepest fall that we've ever
seen in our disposable incomes if we
just kind of come out
you can see that's lower than any other
period that we've we've got all going
all the way back since the beginning of
this kind of the start of this series
which is a long time it's the kind of
the post-war period
and here's the striking thing unless you
know the chancellor hadn't done what
he's done today this is what the office
of budget responsibility has said that
bar would have been even deeper so he
has reduced it somewhat
but he hasn't reduced it as much as he
perhaps could have and as much as some
people might have liked and the upshot
is that you're seeing a very big fall
and this is coming outside of a
recession so very striking indeed and
what's the main cause for that was worth
just looking at some of the other
numbers that we've had from the office
of budget responsibility starting with
inflation inflation is obviously the
number the one big number that really
kind of um encapsulates what we're going
through right now costs are going up
inflation is this measure of how much
the average shopping basket of goods is
going up each year
last time around this is the last time
around so in october the obr the office
of responsibility thought costs were
going up by about four percent
a year that was already really high
double the two percent you'd normally
get that's the bank of england's target
but just look at how that bar's gone up
today we'll add a red one on showing you
today's bar
wow it is up by basically more than
double uh or almost double i should say
uh but that that is you know an enormous
increase it's the biggest since the
creation of the obr we're going to see
the highest level inflation that we've
seen going back generations and that all
goes into our pockets and that's the
issue that the chancellor is facing is
how can he deal with that and what kind
of policies can he introduce that will
actually make that a little bit better
and the question there when it comes to
those policies and just how much of a
difference they're going to make is
what kind of impact are they going to
have here you can see it in fiscal terms
this is just the amount of money that
either is kind of going into the
exchange or coming out anything below
the bar shows that he's spending money
to try to provide extra cash for people
and you can see that in this year that
we're in at the moment the one that
we're going into that's your fuel duty
that's national insurance kicking in
there and then there's smaller giveaways
in the future future years but as i was
saying you know it's nothing to
compensate for what we saw uh in you
know for what we're experiencing this
year the biggest fall in our standard of
living that we have really ever seen uh
going all the way back to 1955. so yes
sir jane it is it is grim i'm afraid and
you know the only kind of reassuring
news is that were it not for some of the
you know the policies we've seen for the
chancellor things might have been a
little bit worse but frankly
he could have potentially done more so
some big questions remaining for the
chancellor and indeed uh we will see
what he says and how he justifies this
and we'll also get a sense from the obr
as to what the implications are for the
rest of us